bienvenidos ahora que ya hemos aprendido
un poco acerca de las leyes de Newton
vamos a aplicarlas para resolver algunos
problemas digamos que tengo un cierto
vehículo un auto una motocicleta o lo
que sea y digamos que su masa es de unos
500 g y digamos que puedo acelerar este
vehículo a unos 3 cm por segundo Eh mi
problema o mi pregunta a resolver es
cuál es la fuerza que Necesito aplicar a
esta masa para acelerarla a esta
velocidad bueno Entonces tenemos
nuestros datos que nuestra masa es igual
a 500
g y nuestra
aceleración era
de 3
cm por segundo al cuadrado y lo que
quiero conocer es la
fuerza bueno Ah También queremos que
Nuestra fuerza sea en
newtons entonces bueno Cuál es la fuerza
que Necesito aplicar para acelerar esta
masa a esta velocidad bueno
eh tenemos que la la segunda ley de
Newton nos dice
que la fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración Así que ustedes podrían
sentirse tentados a sustituir amente los
valores en la fórmula entonces
tendríamos que fuerza es igual a la masa
de 500
g por la aceleración de 3 cm por segundo
cuadrado lo que nos
deja
10000 G por
cm por segundo
cuadrado si lo hacen así estarán bien
pero la respuesta no va a estar en
newtons Y entonces deberán de alguna
manera convertir estas unidades a
newtons y bueno eh Qué es un Newton
recordemos que de los videos pasados
vimos que un Newton es igual a 1
kg por metro por segundo al
cuadrado
entonces Bueno podemos convertir este
resultado transformar sus unidades pero
a mí en lo particular se me hace más
fácil trabajar o convertir la masa y la
aceleración a las unidades correctas
para trabajarlos ya con las unidades
como deben de
ser bueno
Entonces tenemos que nuestra masa son
500 g Cuántos kilos son 500 g bueno
sabemos que eh 1 kg son 1000 G por lo
que 500 gr va a ser igual a 12
kg de igual manera tenemos que la
aceleración es de 3 cm por segundo al
cuadrado Cuántos centímetros hay en 1
metro 1 metro tiene 100
cm por lo que 3 cm va a ser el
equivalente
a 0
punto
0 3
metros por segundo al
cuadrado Espero que comprendan esto sin
problemas ahora tenemos nuestra masa en
kilogramos y nuestra aceleración en
metros por segundo al cuadrado si esto
los confunde Les recomiendo que
consulten los vídeos de conversión de
unidades Bueno vamos entonces a usar las
unidades correctas tenemos que la fuerza
es igual a nuestra má en kilogramos
0.5
kg por
03 m por segundo cuadrado y Eh bueno ya
que estemos las unidades bien eh sabemos
que va a quedar en newtons pero vamos a
hacer esta multiplicación porque a veces
a muchas personas incluyéndome a mí se
nos complica un poco la multiplicación
de decimales entonces hacemos
0.03 por punto 5 multiplicamos los
números nos queda 15 y ahora las eh
lugares decimales Tenemos aquí que hay
dos lugares más este son tres Entonces
tenemos que recorrer el punto decimal
tres lugares hacia la izquierda por lo
que nos
queda punto 015 como fuerza Ahora sí en
newtons y bueno este es el resultado que
quería emos obtener ahora vamos a hacer
otro problema vamos a dividir un poco
esta
área creo que lo más complicado de este
tipo de problemas tanto con las leyes de
Newton como los problemas en general de
fuerza es no olvidarnos de trabajar con
las unidades correctas de cuidar que
siempre las unidades estén
eh
eh convertidas a a las
e a las ahora sí que a las unidades que
queremos lograr al menos o a las
unidades estándar dependiendo de qué es
lo que que queramos
resolver Bueno entonces Ah y si estos
problemas se les dificultan además de la
conversión de unidades otra cosa que
puede que les complique es el álgebra
las matemáticas si esto si tienen
problemas resolviendo estos ahora sí que
resolviendo estos problemas yo yo Les
recomiendo que repasen un poco su
álgebra Pero bueno vamos a regresar a
nuestro
problema y ahora digamos que voy a
aplicar una fuerza en particular una
fuerza conocida que le voy a llamar
F subíndice cero es una un
valor y esta fuerza la voy a aplicar a
una masa conocida m subíndice 0 Y además
voy a tener una aceleración particular a
subíndice
cero igual puedo usar esto con números
pero vamos a trabajar con literales para
hacer esto resolverlo de manera más
general Por ejemplo yo podría decir que
tengo una fuerza de 10 New para una masa
de 2 kg con una aceleración de 5 m por
segundo al cuadrado Pero bueno vamos a
trabajar a seguir trabajando con las l
es o con las
variables Bueno lo que me indica el
problema es que si yo agrego otra masa a
mi masa original Bueno vamos a hacer el
diagrama tengo eh lo que me especifica
el problema es tengo una
masa subíndice c
m0 esta le aplico una fuerza particular
que es f0 y como resultante voy a tener
una aceleración en particular a cero
ahora lo que me indica el problema es
que voy a
tener
eh a esta Bueno voy a dibujar el mismo
sistema tengo la misma
fuerza tengo esta mása
cero pero
ahora lo que tengo es que voy a agregar
otra fuerza encima Perdón voy a agregar
otra masa encima de mi masa original y
esta la voy a llamar
M1 y lo que me dice el problema es que
la aceleración
resultante va a ser una quinta
parte de mi aceleración original a cero
va a ser una quinta
parte lo que me pide el problema es que
yo encuentre Cuál es la relación
o la razón entre estas dos masas Cuál es
la razón de m0 entre
M1 Bueno vamos a mantenerlos con
variables solo para confundirlos un poco
más y después veremos Cómo podemos
sustituir números y veremos que se
resuelve el problema de manera más
sencilla bueno tenemos que de este
sistema mi sistema original tengo que
mi fuerza c era igual a la a la masa sub
índice c por la aceleración sub índice
cer como quiero dejar todo en términos
de las masas voy a despejar m0 y me
queda que m0 es igual paso a la
aceleración
dividiendo F sub índice 0 entre la
aceleración sub índice
c Bueno y ahora tengo este otro problema
ya que agregué mi
me queda que ahora mi misma fuerza f0 es
igual a Ahora va a ser la suma de estas
dos masas masa 0 más masa
1 por mi nueva aceleración que es una
quinta parte de la aceleración anterior
o original multiplicada por
1/5 de aceleración c quiero dejar esto
en términos de las masas por lo que voy
a despejar y me va a quedar
eh
que mis
masas m0 +
M1 es igual a esto lo paso multiplicando
este
eh a esta lado de la ecuación nos va a
quedar
5 por
f0 entre
aceleración 0 y bueno Qué es esta parte
f0 entre a0 Pues resulta que es lo mismo
que despeje acá entonces puedo sustituir
esto por m0 de manera que me va a quedar
m0 + M1 es igual a 5
m0 eh voy a restar m0 en ambos lados y
me va a quedar
M1 es ig a 4
m0 voy
a dejar de lado elor el valor constante
el cuatro entonces queda
M1 entre m0 = 4 y lo puedo
invertir de manera
que mi razón más cero entre masa un es
igual a una cuarta parte que eso es lo
que estoy buscando como respuesta a mi
problema Esto es lo que quería encontrar
Y esto es el
resultado en el siguiente video
resolveremos esto usando números y verán
que así es una manera más fácil de
encontrar el resultado aunque es bueno
acostumbrarse a resolver estos problemas
en términos de ecuaciones generales nos
vemos en el siguiente video ya